All right, that's too bad, always. I'm thrilled
to hear from our Scottish callers, why don't
we go to Nick from Tennessee
next. Nick, you're on the air.
Nick from Tennessee, you're on the air.
Hey, David, can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Hey, thanks for taking my call. My question is
actually about the stock market. It's something
that I've taken an interest in, mainly after
reading Matt Taibbi s journalistic work on the
2008 financial crisis and learning more through
the documentary Capital in the Twenty First
Century. And my question for you is, is
it am I overestimating the impact that
the stock market and financial market has on our
system? Or is it something that doesn't get talked
about due to these sort of inaccessibility
of it and how hard it is to enact change?
Well, you might have to say a bit. No, I think I
think many people accurately understand the impact
of the financial system, the stock market being a
piece of that on our political system. You know,
maybe you could be more specific in terms of the
ways you think are not appreciated enough. But
I think anybody who's paying attention to the
political space in a serious way understands
that the financial system is inextricably
linked to the political system,
both in terms of how the financial system
funds the political system, but also how
it has created sort of this revolving
door of regulatory capture, where you have
the regulators and the industry leaders and
the elected officials all together and often
going from one role to the next. Is there a
specific way you think it's underappreciated?
I know it's tough because I'm just learning about
it, so I'm still sort of finding the excuse me,
the vocabulary to. To express my concern with it,
but, yeah, and learning just the history of how
the stock market essentially took over the economy
as soon as it was introduced or created. And, you
know, around the time just after industrialization
in America and the fact that it has sort of
remained this very powerful presence but doesn't
seem to ever enter the the political arena of
discussion, at least on the level of public
discourse, which we hear from most media sources.
Yeah, and I think I think to some degree,
you're right. I mean, I do think that there's
a superficial analysis of if the stock
market's up, it signals a good economy.
And if it's down, it signals a bad economy. And
of course, the stock market isn't the economy and
stocks are disproportionately held by a relatively
small percentage of people, certainly the vast,
vast majority of the shares. But I think I would
agree with you that there's not a deeper analysis
of the connection between the stock market and the
political system that that maybe would be useful.
But I do think most people
are at least generally aware
of the role of the stock market and how publicly
traded companies, generally speaking, operate.
That's fair, and like I said, I'm still learning
and new to this world, but it's just something
that has really intrigued me lately. And
just one final question for you. And I've
learned through watching your content that you
participate in the stock market. What is your,
I guess, stance on it as a participant from our
on the ground level of being just a consumer
who is also involved in stocks and investing?
Yes. So this isn't financial advice advice. But as
I've said before, you know, my my full time thing
is not picking stocks and making investments.
And even the people who do that full time often
underperform the market averages. So I'm not
arrogant enough to think I'm particularly
good at picking stocks. So my approach is
dollar cost averaging regularly buying more
and more shares of low cost index funds,
which you can get for sometimes five basis points,
meaning point zero five percent fees. Nope,
not paying any managers one one and a half
percent fees for for managing a hedge fund.
Just go with the lowest price index funds.
And then within my portfolio, maybe three to
five percent of my money is in individual stocks
that I have some knowledge of. So, for example,
people know I bought Tesla's stock six years
ago and I have a few other individual stocks.
But my approach as a participant is I'm busy
hosting my show, running a business. I devote
very little time to picking stocks
and I'm just buying the broader index
funds and paying as little as possible in fees.
Cool. Thanks a lot for taking my call. I really
enjoy your show and I look forward to tomorrow.
All right. My pleasure. Nick from Tennessee.